you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
the government announces its
long-awaited net zero strategy wind
nuclear and hydrogen energy are at the
heart of plans to decarbonize the power
system by 2035.
grants for electric vehicles and a zero
emissions mandate for manufacturers to
end the sale of petrol and diesel cars
by 2030
but the prime minister's plans for the
uk to lead the green revolution are
under fire for not going far enough
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
green energy electric cars and
investment in green technologies are at
the center of the government's
long-awaited strategy to cut carbon
emissions to net zero by 2050 in a major
announcement today less than two weeks
away from the global climate summit in
glasgow were planned to boost nuclear
power bring an end to the sale of petrol
and diesel cars and switch away from
home heating powered by gas
but there are questions over how the
plans will be funded and whether they go
far enough to achieve net zero emissions
well why is all this so important well
in 2015 nearly 200 countries signed the
paris agreement to limit global warming
to well below 2 degrees preferably 1.5
degrees compared to pre-industrial
levels and as we can see here we're
currently at 1.2 degrees and that number
is ticking up all the time and the uk's
plan to reduce its emissions relies in
part on a greater use of green energy
and right now we can see that the
country's power generation is currently
made up of 34 renewables we've got 54
coming from fossil fuels at the moment
and we've got 12 percent coming from
nuclear power
our science and technology editor tom
clark now reports
on the fourth quarter of the future
there won't be queues for petrol because
the only thing on sale will be
sustainable locally sourced electrons
well that's one aim of today's net zero
strategy with nearly a billion pounds
more promised for green car grants and
local charging networks
but grants have been around for a while
and many drivers like andy are still
skeptical i think the biggest challenge
is going to be making sure the
infrastructure is in place so that you
know if you've got all these electric
cars on the road well are people
actually going to be able to charge them
yeah so i think that's that's probably
the biggest challenge alongside of
course you know providing
support for people to make greener
choices
you shouldn't be out of pocket for doing
the right thing
in addition to cars there's more money
for heat pumps home efficiency and green
aviation but the billions pledged a
refraction of the money needed to shift
the economy off fossil fuels according
to boris johnson public money provides
the spark for a privately funded
revolution green is good
green is right
green works
we need
urgent government action
but we must mobilize the markets we must
bring in the private sector because i
can i can deploy billions with the
approval of the chancellor obviously
but you
you in this room
you can deploy trillions
but what if the government persuades
everyone to buy electric heat pumps in
cars and then doesn't have enough
electricity to run them
today's strategy promises a new nuclear
power plant probably here next to
sizewell b in suffolk to help fill the
gap
the size of this dome is quite deceptive
because inside the nuclear reactor is
only about four meters across no other
source of energy we've got quite packs
the punch you get from splitting atoms
heat from those nuclear reactions
generates steam which drives this
turbine that makes enough electricity to
more than a million homes and size well
b has got two of these
two proposed reactors here would power
six million more homes the industry says
nuclear is a natural fit
what we've seen the last few weeks has
demonstrated what happens if you're
overly reliant on importing gas at the
same time as having a lot of your power
coming from variable sources consumers
are affected most by the price rises
that nobody can control nuclear gives
you
reliable low carbon power with a very
predictable cost
the success of the strategy depends on
whether businesses can get behind it and
drive down the costs of going green so
we can all afford the benefits
if not net zero ambition will remain
just that
tom clark sky news
well the strategy is laid out in a 360
page report here's our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter with
some of the detail and some reaction to
it the british government has released a
raft of policies today all aimed at
hitting ambitious carbon reduction
targets and demonstrating leadership
ahead of the crucial u.n climate summit
cop26
so what's been announced well the focus
is on those sectors most responsible for
emissions that means decarbonizing the
way we heat our homes so there's a 450
million pound fund to help people switch
from gas boilers to low carbon
alternatives like electric heat pumps
transport is also a big emitter so the
government will invest 620 million
pounds in grants for electric vehicles
and street charging points alongside
other investments in hydrogen and
aviation fuel technologies and of course
all of this electricity we're going to
be using has to be clean or there's no
point so the uk has now committed to
delivering exactly this by 2035 that
means more wind and solar power and an
attempt to approve at least one more
large-scale nuclear power plant in the
coming years
the government says that its net zero
strategy will support
440 000 jobs by 2030 and that tens of
billions of pounds in private and public
money has been mobilized to pay for this
green industrial revolution although the
treasury has said that additional taxes
may be needed if there's a shortfall
so what next well all of these
announcements have been timed to help
boost the uk's position as a climate
leader ahead of the cop 26 meeting in
glasgow which is now just days away
the prime minister says that the uk
strategy sets an example to other
nations to raise their own net zero
ambitions but i've talked to senior
members of the chinese government who
say that won't be the case
china is the world's largest polluter
and has already committed to peak carbon
emissions before 2030 and net zero by
2060.
we do not need the actions taken by the
uk to encourage us
china also set up a very clear road map
together with
a clear time frame policies measures and
actual feasible actions to support its
double
targets
we need
to have the biggest drop
biggest cut on the carbon intensity
compared with all the other countries
this is the best possible efforts we can
make given the current development stage
and the capacity of china
we simply hope all the developed
countries can do the same by honoring
their words with actual actions
the stage is now set for a difficult
climate summit if china continues to be
unwilling to make further concessions on
carbon reduction or on the domestic
phase-out of coal
so as you've been hearing the strategy
has received a mixed response and
there's a huge question remaining about
how it's funded well uh joining me now
from westminster is our deputy political
editor sam coe so sam it's an ambitious
document but what are the political
risks
well anna
the remarkable thing about today is that
britain has become pretty much the first
country uh to set out in this level of
detail um a path to net zero and if you
were to listen to the political debate
the really striking thing is that
there's a political consensus behind it
labor for all of their slightly uh for
their critical rhetoric back this plan
their argument it doesn't go far enough
but would vote for it tomorrow if there
was an opportunity
and while there was grumbling on the
conservative back benches about it uh it
was relatively muted in the scale of
these things so boris johnson has done
something pretty unique which he's that
he's got a political consensus behind
some massive uh massive reforms but when
you go through all of the different
documents uh that the government
published today one thing strikes you
above all which is just how little they
know about what they're signing the
country up to take hydrogen we don't
know whether it's going to be a big part
of the answer to britain's net
zero question by 2050 because the trials
haven't taken place yet that'll only be
resolved in maybe 2026
um if you look at the question of
mortgages last night on sky news we
revealed uh the
the government intends to make mortgage
lending harder if it's against a house
that's uh drafty or less well insulated
how is that going to work that's a big
unknown as we go forward
and then there are just massive parts of
documents that suggest wholesale change
that could provoke massive political
unpopularity let me read you one section
they say those on lower income jobs are
more likely to work in high carbon
production industries which will have to
be decarbonized and those jobs will be
phased out and replaced with greener
equivalent in other words entire
industries are going to disappear
and hopefully replaced by greener
equivalents that is not without
political risk and that's before you get
to the questions of tax uh what's going
to replace fuel duty once petrol and
diesel cars are phased out and electric
equivalents are introduced any one of
those things could smash the political
consensus that exists today it's fragile
because the westminster political system
has effectively signed up uh a blank
check in perpetuity uh for a goal that
they agree with but on a path that
they're not sure
what what it is so boris johnson has
been ambitious but he's going to have to
keep being ambitious on this subject if
he's going to maintain that kind of
levels of agreement
sam thanks very much indeed
well in some of the day's other climate
news boris johnson and bill gates have
launched a 400 million pound partnership
to invest in early-stage green
technologies the prime minister says the
government will invest 200 million
pounds with mr gates's clean energy fund
breakthrough energy ventures matching
the figure the money will be used for
projects that focus on green hydrogen
sustainable aviation fuel and carbon
capture technology
drax is being dropped from an investment
index of clean energy companies as
doubts grow over the sustainability of
burning wood biomass pellets the company
which receives hundreds of millions of
pounds in renewable energy subsidies was
axed after s p global dow jones changed
its methodology it comes after analysis
shared with sky news suggested that
drax's plant in north yorkshire is the
uk's largest single emitter of carbon
dioxide drax has disputed that claim
and scientists are venturing into ice
caves growing beneath glaciers in
austria to study why they're melting
faster than expected the eastern alpine
glaciers were built up over millions of
years but glaciologists say they'll be
completely gone in the next few decades
the team hopes the information they
gather could help better manage the
decline of glaciers in other parts of
the world
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'll be joined by carbon footprint
printing expert mike berners-lee and
judy ling wong honorary president of the
black environment network and we're
going to be discussing more about how
the netseries strategy will affect
consumers in the uk
so i started in mobile alabama oh which
is there
and then i carried on going to santa
monica california um
should be there
and then up to maine up at the top
over the top down to san francisco
across to south carolina
i feel like a weather man this is great
and then i finished in monument valley
uh which is the infamous point where
forest just turned round and and left
his followers hanging but fortunately
they've stuck with me
i ran for two charities the world
wildlife fund and peace direct
all stem
from a promise that my mom uh sort of uh
made me stick to uh before she passed
away which was
to do one thing in my life that made a
difference and that was a pretty
profound thing you know for a young man
to try and you know still ascertain
where that future lay and eventually
all the little ducks went into a row and
i realized that this was my thing this
was my opportunity to make that
difference
how long did it take you rob
uh
422 days which is a little bit quicker
than forest but uh
maybe some shoe technologies moved on
how many miles in total
uh so i think it's 15
621 as far as the watch said uh that's
an average of 37 a day
wow wow what was the hardest part
well sort of uh let's let's take away
the board and stuff like the financial
thing because it was self-supported we
we had a house deposit then we didn't
have a house deposit but hey i guess
that's what happens in the shooting
making a difference right um by a few
cracking injuries i i tore my quad uh
just across the mississippi for the
second time and i was stuck inside a
mobile home with the memphis blues again
for a couple of days and um i had food
poisoning texas where i lost the exact
midpoint of route 66 and i lost six
kilos in five days um
minus 18 degrees in wyoming um sort of
plus 43 sort of up in montana in the
summer i thought the weather was gonna
be like scotland well it's more like
italy i just got to a place that was the
middle of nowhere and just like forest i
was pretty tired so i went home
[Music]
[Music]
did you know if more of us walked rolled
bikes and scooted to school we would
make a big difference to the air
pollution around our school yeah like us
wednesday will start mostly fine but the
very mild south will have some rain that
rain heavy and thundery in places will
mostly clear across england wales and
island during the morning leaving
sunshine and blustery showers elsewhere
it'll be mainly fine but the windy
northwest of scotland looks wet it'll be
cooler than recently
the afternoon will see rain moving
across scotland with snow on the
mountain tops the unsettled conditions
mean that the air pollution index where
1 means low pollution and 10 means very
high will stay low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
honorary president of the black
environment network judy lin wong and
carbon footprinting expert mike
berners-lee so welcome to both of you
and of course the big story today a lot
for us to focus on a lot for us to read
the uk government has released an
avalanche of documents strategies
consultations research all based around
the drive to reach its target of net
zero emissions by 2050. so mike to you
first of all a huge amount to digest but
what's your instinct are the policies
and the investment there for us to reach
net zero on time
i think overall i feel i feel a bit sad
about it because um it does have a lot
of you know um
good things in there they're just not
scaled up to the point that we need them
i think
um
just to give a sense of perspective on
the scale i think i added up something
like two and a half million pounds a
year's worth of government spending
which is like um well defense spending
is maybe 20 times that size and we're
talking about 27 billion pounds worth of
spending um on new road infrastructure
so it just hasn't got the perspective
right for a climate emergency which is
kind of such a shame
um in the run-up to the cop when
everyone's looking at us to see whether
we're clear how coherent and serious we
really are but mike isn't the hope that
there'll be lots of private investment
that will come in
yeah and maybe that will
maybe that will help us but if i look at
the scale of
uh of what's being
um what's being trumpeted here you know
i i think you know they've under-egged
the new jobs opportunity and if you look
for example at um what they're talking
about for uh heat pumps if you look at
the you know there's there's um you know
some spend on on subsidizing heat pumps
but that that equates to helping about
one household in every thousand
every year to get a heat pump which is
you know that's a small that's a small
pinprick
of a dent in the problem okay and judy
what's your overall thought does this
look like a credible plan to you
i see there's a very expensive industry
based action around technology i do not
see as a formula that can enable people
lower income to participate right now or
less wealthy countries in the world to
follow this formula i mean there's a
delay they talk about cheaper prices to
comments on how long that's going to
take is anyone's guess
and i think that what we really need to
do in the meantime because of the delay
is to pay more attention to
people-centered actions that can make a
big difference for example food waste
graphically represented you know as a
point of emission food waste
drawn as a country would be the third
largest country in the world
well yes and let's talk about the cost
to individuals shall we mike because i
know that a recent poll said for example
that the public supports most climate
policies unless there's a personal cost
and you can understand that can't you so
going back to that heat pumps issue
which has been a big kind of attention
grabber in all of this
is there enough
financial support and incentive for
people to switch away from gas boilers
here
well there's there's some incentive but
but almost certainly not enough i mean i
think you know we've touched on on the
sort of the big sadness for the the
opportunity that hasn't yet been taken
here because this whole low-carbon
transition plan could be served up in a
way that is financially attractive for
the average household and i think we've
we've just heard the point here that is
really really important and it's all
about putting together a proper coherent
package by which okay something some
really high carbon things in life are
going to get more expensive but overall
there's an opportunity for the average
there should be an opportunity for the
average household to actually be better
off especially if they take some
behavior change um you know in this
low-carbon transition what's not to like
about it along with the millions of new
low-carbon jobs that we could be having
the government's talking about some of
that but overall it just hasn't got it
yet a package that's properly attractive
to everyone in the uk and that's such a
shame because it could be
and of course judy for heat pumps to be
green uh we need electricity to come
from green sources we need more of it as
well so what about that switch to make
the grid greener and cleaner does that
sound like a credible plan that's on the
table there
i mean some of it is credible because we
the technology is coming and so on and
we talk about lots of green jobs and if
there's lots of green jobs that's a
great thing but this people dimension
keep coming back to is really important
for example if you look at the gender
dimension which of those jobs they are
actually thinking about appeals to the
female population you know even if you
look at something very simple
gender-based all the power tools are
based on the size and the weight of a
man's hand you know all these things
really matter in images on how the
population participates in this
industrial revolution
that that's a whole other area that we
could talk about sometime
but perhaps we haven't got the time to
to delve now but
mike what about leadership at cop26 uk a
host is this the kind of plan that boris
johnson can walk in and go look we're
doing this in the uk all you other
countries have to step up
is it enough
well i think my fear is that the
government underestimates just how
smart and discerning a lot of the people
going along to cop26 are going to be
because you know it doesn't i don't
think it takes a rocket scientist to be
able to look at this strategy and see
that it's not it's not really enough
and it could be much better and it
doesn't quite have the coherence that we
could be seeing so you know i'm sad
about that because i think you know that
the most of the attendees uh the cop
will understand that this isn't really a
proper serious strategy that is fully um
uh
fully aligned with the scale of the
challenge that we face and it's a shame
because the opportunity to actually
rearrange the uk economy a bit and steer
it in a way that it absolutely can uh
you know can be leading in such an
opportunity it's even such a huge
economic opportunity as well if we were
to push the button really hard
on all the new technologies we need and
all the new skills that we need for the
global low carbon transition
very briefly judy a quick thought of
what could have been in it was there a
big idea you think they missed
well i think the approach to
negotiations is a big one we've got to
collaborate as a world and kindness and
consideration for other countries is an
element that's missing we're constantly
talking about china's kind of demonized
polluter and and so on but
the aggregate pollution is because
there's billions of people there and the
per capita pollution is actually making
chinese we look at it for way down the
list and the uk rise right up the list
when you talk of historical things and
per capita and so so a generosity about
how we move forward together and finding
solutions together and of course not
such only expensive industrialized
solutions would really help the world
okay well thank you so much for your
thoughts i'll let you go back and read
every single page of all those documents
it could keep you up all night but for
the moment judy linguang and mike
berners-lee thanks both very much indeed
well that's everything from us for today
do join us on the show tomorrow to
discuss all the big climate issues i'm
going to be joined by lecturer in
international relations jen allen and
muhammad ado director of the think tank
power shift africa do stay with us sky
news tonight is up next
[Music]
you